(moving piano music)
- We wanted to rethink food.
And create something extraordinary.
Introducing, Fri.
Carefully preserving color and texture
permitted our most elegant model yet.
We combined multiple incarnations of oil
to create an all-permeating substance
we like to call Smart Grease.
Smart Grease allows the
user to know exactly
where Fri is, or where it has ever been.
Fri. Enhanced food for the modern world.
But that's not all.
Introducing, Nugget.
Nugget is what happens
when machinery meets meat.
When you look at Nugget, you
see not the contents inside.
You see the breading outside.
That was intentional.
Inside this advanced piece of food, we can
examine the complexity
that makes up this product.
To change the way we experience
chicken is to change chicken itself.
Oh, and, one more thing.
Mac.
We have refined, and refined, and...
Refined basic ingredients.
The sesame seeds on the bun are
there because we put them there.
The feel of the Mac is
somewhere between firm and soft.
The people who are hungry enough
to eat the Mac are those who do.
(moving piano music)